welcome to the Google cloud platform
education series my name is Jeff Davis
and in this session we'll discuss
analyzing your data in less time using
Google bigquery we'll be running a
moderated QA during the session so feel
free to use the ask your question field
at the bottom of your screen to submit
questions as we go along let's get
started
so the agenda for this session will be
starting out with a series of demos will
show you typical use cases and the speed
at which bigquery operates and how easy
it is to use then we'll talk about the
general set of features for bigquery and
how you might be able to leverage them
in your environment we'll talk about how
to find answers to questions after you
leave today's session and you get
started working with bigquery on your
own we'll talk about some best practices
for evaluating bigquery in your
environment and again we'll be doing Q&A
as we go along so submit those questions
let's start with a series of demos that
show both big queries scale as well as
how easy it is to integrate in other
systems that you use for data analysis
and reporting what we have here is the
web UI that allows end users to easily
play with data with in bigquery we're
going to show you some integrations
later on but right now this is just for
doing quick iterative analysis of large
data sets so let's start with some
sample data sets that Google makes
available so for instance here we have
airline on-time data so we have a list
of flights and if we take a look at this
table you can see it's about an 8 gig
file it's 70 million rows of data
regarding different airlines on-time
arrival and departure performance in
different states and so forth and I want
to get some information so I'm going to
start with a canned query that I've got
here ok and this is going to find all
the arrival entries just for United
Airlines so I'm going to copy this go
back and query the table
okay you can see I'm using standard
sequel I'm going to be querying the
flight stable looking for all rows where
the airline code is 1990 77 that's the
code for United Airlines and I'm going
to select three columns from every row
now I'm going to disable caching because
we want to see how long it takes to do
an initial query against the 70 odd
million rows you'll notice it gives me
an estimate of how much data it's going
to have to process this is also useful
for estimating how much it's going to
cost and that you pay I think it's five
dollars per terabyte of data processed
after the first terabyte so this uses
some fraction of that so I'm going to
run this and it should take between 25
to 30 seconds to complete the query when
it comes back it will show us the three
rows for all the columns that will give
us a column count and then we'll move on
to a slightly more interesting query
that gives us some more insight into our
data so you'll notice it took 23 point
eight seconds process two gigabytes of
data it returned let's see that looks
like 500 or five million forty-three
thousand five hundred seventy eight rows
so it's a lot of data returned that's
part of why it took so long to come back
it would have been faster if there had
been fewer rows and the results set so
what this does is it just gets us the
date the arrival state and the arrival
delay I would like to get a little bit
more insight so what I'm going to do is
run this query this query should tell me
the average delay by month by arrival
state for United Airlines so I want to
see what months are the worst and what
states are the worst so let's run this
again it's going to process the same
amount of data that came back quite a
bit faster and you'll notice that we
have 5,000 rows instead of five million
rows returned that's part of why it came
back
quickly and you'll notice that what
we've got is for each state
we've got individual months and for
those months we've got the average delay
the number of flights the number of
flights that were early the number of
flights that were late the percentage of
flights that were early and the
percentage of flights that were late so
this is using the lingua franca of data
analysis it's using standard sequel it's
not that difficult to write there's no
actual query optimization here you'll
notice I'm also using sub queries that's
perfectly valid and I was able to very
quickly get back insights from a very
large collection of data so again you
can do this all interactively through
the web UI let's actually look at just
scale how fast can this go on really big
data sets so you think well Jeff 75
million rows that's a pretty big data
set well it's not as big as some of
these data sets for instance so for
instance Wikimedia Wikipedia benchmark
data and if you look you can see that
the table basically has got year month
day project language title and view so
this has got data about how many times
particularly million row version we have
a 10 million row version a 100 million
row version a billion row version let's
see how this all scales so we'll start
with a million I'm going to turn off the
standard sequel and use legacy sequel
just for giggles so we're going to query
a million articles we're looking for all
articles that have Davis because I'm
fairly vain I'm going to look for
articles about people with my same last
name we're going to use a regex
expression to match these and what I
want to do is actually group them by
title and sum the number of views so
let's do this over a million row data
set this is 47 megabytes and that should
come back fairly quickly so you'll
notice Anthony Davis and Thomas Davis
are the most frequent
viewed articles in the 1 million entry
data set let's look at ten million okay
so we go from 47 megabytes to 476
megabytes and we go from just a couple
of seconds to three seconds we now have
20 flee 2500 results Daniel Davis is the
top now so this was three seconds to do
10 million let's do a hundred million
you see where we're going with this you
want to know if I'm going to get to the
hundred billion number and I am I'm
going to have to pay 20 bucks out of my
pocket to run that query but I'll do it
just for you so you notice I Jefferson
Davis not my namesake it's a coincidence
favorite jazz musician Miles Davis is up
there so we've done a hundred million
let's do Oh what the heck that's two
seconds let's do a hundred billion this
is going to process three point six four
terabytes of data one hundred billion
rows cross our fingers get out my ATM
card and yet think about it $20 to run
this query versus the amortized cost of
a query against a big teradata system or
some other big data rig that you've got
it's going to give you equivalent
performance it's actually a heck of a
value so I think it's about 30 to 50
seconds to complete the query while
that's running I'm going to get so
actually it's done so 37 seconds notice
it came back with a hundred and eighty
five thousand rows and the results and
it has aggregated and told me that Miles
Davis is in fact the most popular
article within the hundred billion row
data set so think about 30 seconds to do
analysis on 100 billion rows I could sit
here and iterate on my queries interact
almost in real time with my data
very very easily now obviously doing
this interactively with the web UI is
one thing another thing is to actually
expose this data pull it out of bigquery
and expose it through some other
applications so we have an example here
this is a customer success application
that pulls data from bigquery so let's
take a look at one of the dashboards if
you went to the App Engine session you
saw this dashboard earlier this has
basically got a bunch of visualizations
of different types of user engagement
metrics within my product and what this
allows me to do is pull the data out of
bigquery through a pis and represent it
in code so behind the scenes here I've
got a user event table now this table is
paltry five hundred thousand rows but
it's not you know it's a modest amount
of data for the usage of this product
and it's a demo application so it
doesn't have kinds of millions of rows
what we do then is we write a little bit
of code to access this and here is
here's the code we're going to go to
bigquery this is a little Python script
you'll notice what we do is we import a
library so Google has code libraries or
client libraries available for a variety
of different languages and it's quite
simple we create a bigquery client we
connect to the data set and then within
the data set we connect to a table and
within the table we are then going to
run a query so here we've got if we want
to run an arbitrary query for instance
we take our client we run a query we
designate the query we give it a timeout
so this makes sure that the query has up
to 45 seconds to run we run the query
and then we simply iterate through the
results and this allows us to process
through the results of the query if you
want to write to bigquery it's quite
straight
where you simply take the table and you
insert a row and this adds Yvette's into
the back end so this data gets written
automatically then the API pulls it out
and renders it in dashboards within your
application now you may be using a
different tool to do your visualization
and reporting you may not use the web UI
and you may not want to go so far as to
write a custom - boring application
let's say you want to use something like
tableau or looker or in this case I'm
using a product called mode analytics
these bi visualization and analysis
tools allow you to connect to bigquery
as a back-end so you'll notice over here
let me make this a little bit bigger
you'll notice I have data sources if I
click on the plus sign I can actually
select a back-end data source and I want
to connect to bigquery okay so saying I
want to connect to bigquery and wants to
know my project ID so I am going to pick
my project ID which is GCP webinar demos
GCP webinar demos and then I need to
create a service account and so the
service account is created through I am
the Identity and Access Management and
you'll notice that I've got a variety of
service accounts here I can go ahead and
create a new service account actually
sorry service accounts are here
those were the roles I'm going to create
a new service account and I'm going to
call this mode and I want to give this
service account bigquery admin
permissions so that it can create tables
delete tables read data and so forth and
I want to get a new private key and
because I read the mode documentation I
know that it needs to be a p12 key so
I'm going to create this service account
and I get the credentials ok and
I'm going to open up actually will
cancel out of that I don't want to put
in my keychain we'll just skip over that
part we go back to mode and we say we've
got to give the name of the service
account so the name of the service
account or the email address here is
this
so we designate that and then we have to
upload the key file and that should be
the key file and if all went well this
is now connected my tool with bigquery
so I can create a new query let's pick
one that looks a lot like what I was
using before let's not use the hundred
billion we can use the 100 million okay
now I need to enter query so I'm going
to go pick one of my pre-canned queries
let's go ahead and use the standard
sequel format for getting information
about United on-time arrival I can paste
that in it will run the query it gives
me a tabular version of the results and
if I want to I can create a chart for
instance that shows on-time arrival I
can change the chart type if I want to
this sort of thing so this shows how you
can do analysis and visualization within
a third party tool so you can fit
bigquery into your normal data analysis
and analytics workflows pretty cool okay
let's switch back and talk about big
queries functionality overall we showed
you some pieces of it let's highlight
additional capabilities and use cases so
that you'll have a better understanding
of how to apply it in your environment
so again bigquery is is fully managed
massive scale low cut cost
enterprise data warehouse the Google
provides running on top of their compute
storage and networking infrastructure
there is a demo query that I've seen at
some conferences that when you run it it
takes 3300 cores 330 hard drives and 330
gigabits of network bandwidth for 30
seconds to complete now those are
tremendous numbers but because Google
has so much available capacity they're
able to give you a slice of 30 seconds
with that level of resources to run your
query and then claw those resources back
and deploy them against somebody else's
query there's no infrastructure for you
to manage you'll often hear this
referred to as being server list well
it's clearly not serverless because
there are servers involved but you don't
have to deal with any servers you focus
just on getting your data in and on
analyzing your data you don't have to
worry about standing up servers tearing
down server's configuration updates any
of that stuff
so when you perform queries you're going
to get results really really quick so we
showed scanning terabytes of data in
roughly 35 seconds at the petabyte level
you're talking a few minutes so this
actually makes turning around analysis
on huge data sets very very fast which
means better analysis more creativity
more interesting insights that you can
derive it uses standard sequel I showed
you that there is a legacy sequel syntax
but in the newest generation of their
query language is ANSI 2011 sequel
compliant so you can actually lift
queries from other environments and with
very little tweaking if any they will
run in a bigquery environment you can
use the web UI as I demonstrated or you
can use third-party tools of choice like
looker tableau click they've got date
partition tables so you can actually
have bigquery automatically partition
time series data by day
or by date and this allows you to have
much higher performance queries you can
also have big query query against
external data sources so you can have a
bunch of data inside of bigquery and
then you can join that data against
external source data as well how do you
get these massive amounts of data into
bigquery well you can do this
interactively like you can upload files
through the web UI or you can use the BQ
command-line utility and upload a file
from your local PC however obviously
that's going to work better for a few
megabytes of data than it will for a few
terabytes of data so there are other
ways that make more sense for
transferring really large volumes you
can stream data directly into bigquery
at a hundred thousand rows per second so
one of the things that we did at hi-5
this video conferencing startup that I
used to work at is we actually would
generate so you had 10,000 users and
calls for all 10,000 calls we were
generating second-by-second Kalama tree
data on hundreds of different counters
on every single call we were writing
that into a production database but then
streaming it into bigquery and bigquery
was the data store from which the
customer-facing team dashboards drew all
of their data Google Cloud dataflow is a
data pipeline framework that allows you
to easily stand up
ETL sort of transformation jobs that
take data from incoming sources
manipulate the data and write them out
into some target repository dataflow
works beautifully with bigquery and so
you can easily be processing batch data
or streaming data and pumping it through
a transformation engine into bigquery
there's also the newly announced
bigquery transfer service where you can
set up regular transfers of your YouTube
data your double-click data and your
AdWords data and have that stream
automatically into bigquery for
performing analytics there will be
additional services coming to bigquery
transfer serve
in the future right now through middle
of 2017 bigquery transfer service is
free after the after the midpoint in the
year you it will become a billable
monthly service availability and access
your data is replicated across multiple
geographies what that means is that the
durability and availability are through
the roof if you have a device go down if
you have a zone go down if you have a
region go down you're still going to be
able to get access to your data and you
will not lose any data you also then can
control who can access that data so
there are identity and access management
roles that you can assign so you can say
developers can write data and your
analysts can read data or your end users
can read data you also can set
permissions at the per data set level
you have really high availability as I
mentioned a 99.9% SLA unavailability the
data that you store in bigquery is
encrypted at rest we mentioned the fact
that you can use iam roles and the fact
that you can either go through command
line or web UI or external clients
pricing so there's two components to
pricing for bigquery there's a storage
component and a query processing
component so the storage component you
pay two cents per gigabyte per month if
you store the data for longer than 30
days you actually get a discount on that
so if the data doesn't change but you
keep querying against it the price
automatically goes down you pay $5 per
terabyte of data processed for queries
the first terabyte is free for companies
that do more than 10 thousand dollars a
month in analytics processing on a
monthly basis they can actually get flat
rate pricing and you by what are called
slots
sort of
technical but it's a different model for
processing fees and you can get what
essentially is a discount by using flat
rate pricing if your volume goes above
$10,000 a month certainly up to about 40
$50,000 a month
talk to your Google sales rep and they
can hook you up it should be noted that
bigquery is not a replacement for every
data enterprise enterprise data store
it's not a transactional relational
database so if you're looking to read
and write into individual cells in rows
in a table and constantly update that
that's not what this is for bigquery is
data that you write in you don't change
the data but you're doing reporting
against the data similarly it's not an
operational data store and it is a
cloud-based solution so if you have an
application that requires on-premise
data warehousing bigquery would not work
for that but you want to ask yourself
are the benefits of bigquery worth
making the changes necessary in our
workflow to put this data in the cloud a
lot of organizations didn't think that
they would want to or be able to do
their data warehousing in the cloud are
finding that the benefits are great
enough that they can find creative ways
to make it work so given this you want
to work with your internal teams to
figure out what can we do with bigquery
so what shine technologies did was they
were working with a customer that did a
huge amount of internet advertising and
what this customer wanted to be able to
present to their executives was a live
dashboard that showed the performance of
their ads so what needed to have was the
ability to stream millions and millions
of ad impressions into bigquery generate
the analytics on this constantly updated
data set that had billions of rows and
do complex query
to drive insights and then visualize
these and shine was able to do this
without any hadoop clusters without any
sort of sophisticated systems operations
investment and they were able to deliver
the clients dashboards that would
consistently in twenty five to twenty to
thirty seconds render visualizations of
up-to-date data save tons of money
actually became a product that they were
able to start delivering to other
customers as well now when you walk away
from today's session you may have
queries as you're trying things out you
may need guidance on how to perform
certain tasks so where do you look for
data or information how do you find what
you're looking for so as always you want
to start with search and just type in
bigquery and your topic so for instance
you want to know how to get data into
bigquery bigquery ingestion and you'll
notice you've got preparing data for
loading streaming data in improving data
ingestion times and so forth okay so for
instance this article talks about using
Avro which compresses the data before it
transmitted and decompresses it on the
other end this is built into bigquery
it makes data loading much more
efficient there's also the typical sort
of table of contents in bigquery
documentation so let me actually take
you a quick tour so if we type in
bigquery up here at the top will be sort
of the splash page from google you could
click on view bigquery Docs you'll get
the typical table of contents there's a
QuickStart here actually - one for the
web UI one for the command-line these
get you up and running in less than five
minutes they give you sort of a very
quick taste and then you've got a drill
down into how-to guides so you can see
how do I load data how do I prepare the
data before I load it
how do I transform the data how do I
load it from data store or status or
cloud storage or via API how do I stream
it in and then here's how do I do
queries
and there's a section down here and you
know how do I export data and then
general basics around security and
management and so forth so pretty
well-organized reasonably exhaustive
reference should be very useful to you
now I don't have a prescribed
methodology for how to do an evaluation
of bigquery because it really depends on
your applications I've heard sort of two
very different approaches commonly used
by companies that have large-scale data
warehousing needs one is to take your
top half-dozen queries so your top half
dozen jobs that are breaking on your
existing infrastructure or just take a
long time and move them to bigquery so
you just pick five or six queries you
load your data you run the query as you
see how much better they are if they're
better great you're ready to go on the
other end of the spectrum are companies
where they really are going to be very
methodical and exhaustive about the way
they do the evaluation so before they
can move any of their data into the
cloud they have to do compliance and
regulatory research they have to cleanse
all of their data they may need to
anonymize the data they load massive
amounts of data and then they
essentially replicate their existing
analytics workflows in bigquery and then
they may go so far is to actually do
blind taste tests so they have their
front-end representation be identical
but they have half of the users go
through the new bigquery enabled
pipeline and half the users go through
the old and they judge the efficacy the
level of satisfaction and so forth so
it's going to be up to you and it will
depend on what vertical you're in what
data you're looking at and so forth
certainly quick and dirty way to get a
sense of what the potential benefits are
is to do the you know half dozen queries
and then depending on your long-term
applications you may need to do a much
more exhaustive proof-of-concept so
that's it for this session thanks so
much for joining us I hope
we found it interesting and helpful we
are going to send you a follow-up email
and it will have a link to a code lab so
you'll get sort of a guided walk through
of bigquery that you can do on your own
we'd love to get your feedback so feel
free to provide the feedback in the UI
in front of you and please stay tuned
for the next session